atlanta
and something that's popping here in
is uh
tip
tip t the king the rubber band man
he's doing comedy
and uh it's it's not
going great
in some cases i mean
yeah
which is but
to be expected as anyone starting at
comedy that's the best part about comedy
is fame has nothing to do with it like
you can be famous for five minutes but
then after that where are the jokes you
know oh
that's that's the realest thing right
there yeah and i think the pro part of
the problem is
he's
he's he's coming out as tip and ti
and he needs to just come out as
clifford harris
that would be interesting
like we need to stop like
stop pretending that you're not like
t.i.p went to jail you know what i'm
saying clifford harris like pays taxes
[Laughter]
yeah like just that's what we need to
see because like
he's got is too much baggage
around seeing
the king of the south like that's too
much
to be like oh yeah yeah this is the king
of the south now he wants to try comedy
it's like
no
like the reason and i think what part of
it is like who was it i think uh
kevin hart did the whole chocolate
dropper
thing right comedic right right it was
all comedic and he was never actually
ever
a real rapper that was the whole point
like he actually never did anything good
at rapping the whole
time it's kind of like me pursuing rap
yes
it almost like hit you all at once yes
that's right
that's right but here's the thing i
would believe that you could pursue rap
because i think you'd take it and you'd
be like yo let me actually work on the
skill set of rapping
ti is completely like
just
trying to make his own rules in the
comedy game like he's going like he went
up after a headliner
already like destroyed a stage
was that was that the one he bombed at
the barclays
no but he did bomb at the barclays but
i actually know people that were at the
show that he did after godfrey went up
in that atlanta comedy theater and it
wasn't good
like he went up after godfrey atlanta
comedy theater i think so i no it might
not have been a comedy theater but he
went up after godfrey wow
yeah like you know there's nothing you
can say
after godfrey just headlines the show
who's been doing it i think two three
months
like you just don't have those bars
it but it's at every level even like did
you see him at the open mic here in
atlanta where him and lauren knight got
into it
yeah yes
yes
and it's like
first of all
uh
you weren't supposed to do 30 minutes
like that's not okay at an open mic no
one does 30 minutes at an open mic
[Music]
but i think part of it is no one's also
telling him hey don't do 30 minutes at
an open mic
because no one wants to
tell that to ti like no one's be like
hey yo uh mr t.i could you uh but they
would tell me clifford clifford would do
five minutes they would i would
definitely pull over clifford i was like
clifford hey man you can't be doing no
30 minutes up there
calm down clifford
that's not that's those are there's
different rules to this game clifford
but mookie mookie said
everything you can do wrong is a new
comic he's doing so it's literally i
mean it literally is like
a new comic came in
doesn't know the rules doesn't know the
system
and it's just like i'm gonna be a
comedian like literally
anybody could make these mistakes
oh anyone can make these mistakes but
here's what i refuse to believe i refuse
to believe that somebody hasn't told him
and he's like
listening this isn't like oh
i'ma go up and
like someone said to him you got like
when you were given a mic at an open mic
people tell you oh it's five minutes
when you see it's not like he wasn't
there before the open mic and seeing
people do five minutes
seeing the light
behind
and being like oh
uh oh
i wonder what that is i guess maybe
someone's just trying to get their
attention no you know what the light is
you've been to a lot of open mics
but you're it's like it's deliberately
going over your time
but he's doing it because he's ti he's
not doing it like it's just
so like he's bringing his bravado into
the scene and it's like yo
first of all you're not going to get
funnier that way and you're not going to
make any friends
but i guess maybe he just doesn't care
i think
it's tough
if you're ti
i mean
you know
yes it's it's tough to know
i mean if you're ti it's kind of like
yeah i am entitled to
cut the line a little bit i mean he is
t.i
but he is he would be funny
you can cut the line all you want
if you bring
hahas right
yeah yeah people people be like hell
yeah ti is in the building y'all he is
about to destroy this he is about to go
after this headline and completely
destroy y'all right give it up for mr
t.i clifford harris peter
we'd all be happy to do that but that's
not what's happening
facts
yeah
but i think like
oh is there wait on my end
oh okay
um but i feel like so what do you what
do you tell ti like what what advice
would you give to ti if ti was to write
hot breath
what advice what are the top three
things you would tell ti to do
tomorrow
besides quit
um
[Music]
besides quit but i think you tell every
comedian to quit that's true i do do
that
i do do that
advice number one quits quick comedy
um
i would tell him to
get a tight five
learn how to write jokes
yeah i would start yeah with
chris o'connor said watch earthquake
everything is on earthquake
the barometer is earthquake now like
he's everywhere
oh but yeah i mean i would tell yeah you
gotta like start with the fundamentals
and then
kind of
make them your own from there but
i think he's got to first learn how to
write a joke
you know no no offense to him literally
literally everyone starts here and he
should have an advantage because he's
been writing for so long
and he understood like there's punch
lines and rap and things
even if he told a funny story like i
haven't seen his act honestly like i've
only seen the clips here and there so i
don't know what he's currently doing
but yeah based on just
comedians reaching out to me in general
i would say like first
get a tight five-minute set together
like whatever you think a tight
five-minute set is like just get five
minutes together not 50
not 30
after a headliner
five minutes it's tight 65.
and it's like
another one would be to like you know
treat
the shows with respect you know don't go
up
like run the light he the thing that he
did with lauren knight he like went up
and like took the mic from her and like
they had this whole back and forth like
that's just something
as a comedian
you don't even think
that that's like appropriate like you
never think i'm going on stage with this
comedian and taking their microphone
you know what i mean
so i would say like write a f type five
minute set to the best of your ability
what that means to you but five minutes
respect the show meaning like don't run
the light don't heckle
don't do any of that
and um the third would be to come on hot
breath and let's talk about it i think
those are the top three
tips yo
if ti gave us his set
we'd make him tight we'd get him so
tight
pause but yeah yeah
we do said reviews
so i mean
we do said review shouting
oh yes for sure yeah i mean and i think
that's that's the key is
like
it feels like no one's in his ear
given him the game
of comedy but he's got connections but
he's
he did a show with like david chappelle
like i remember when dave chappelle was
in town
dave chappelle walked in with t.i
to the laughing skull and
for two hours like they're tight and
it's like yo chappelle get your boy
somebody needs to be like yo get them
get some jokes you know what i mean yeah
i wonder what people are telling him
behind the scenes because i know yeah i
know he knows plenty of comedians who
are who would like tell him
like you know the right way to be doing
things so hopefully these are all just
like
learning
experiences that he's kind of having to
learn
under a microscope because he is ti but
yep uh hopefully he is getting the right
feedback because i'm
i'm personally rooting for him like i i
want to see him succeed i want to see
him kill it
but
this is the thing everyone is learning
that one everyone that wants to pursue
comedy has to learn
these early struggles of like oh you
mean i don't get a microphone and then a
netflix special you mean there's a whole
there's a whole chasm in between there
so
i'm rooting for him i want him to kill
it and succeed and really put comedy on
an even bigger
platform than it's already on i hope
that for him
but he's got to learn the kind of learn
the fundamentals first
yeah for sure but i also think
in the way that he responded to
godfrey it almost feels like he also
wants to like
make his own lane and write his own
rules about the way that comedy works
and that for me is like you know i i get
that you want to just do your own thing
and you're your own person
but
these laughs still have to happen humor
isn't just you just don't become an
overnight success there are 10-year
successes earthquake is a 30-year
overnight success yeah for sure
you know what i mean like you just don't
all of a sudden to your point just get a
netflix special because you're ti you
still have to be funny you still have to
be like relatable and it feels like he's
trying to bypass those things
just because he feels like oh this is
just something that i can get and i
don't know the man personally but it
just
i feel like if
you have enough people in your corner
rooting for you
someone should be like yo this is the
rules of comedy because obviously
there's rules of rap it's not like a
rapper just overnight just be like
starts rapping and then gets a gets on
grand hustle and has a major deal
has he ever started one like overnight
just be like oh yeah this guy started
two months ago rapping would he sign
someone to his record
who's been rapping for two months
right
yeah yeah that's a good point
yeah i mean he's doing like the fact
that even took
the barclays gig and was like yo yo
i'mma tell jokes at this huge venue are
you kidding me and then get bomb and
then bomb and then get booed and then he
played a song
because
that's
the only thing you can do in that moment
he had to he clifford turned into t.i
real quick
yeah he's like play it hit it dj
oh and ryan shrilla said
i hope i pronounced that right ryan i'm
sorry buddy but he came uh
he came to the show at cultivation
uh last time uh he said it's a crazy
time of comedy i'm appreciative of your
pod and guidance not going to worry
about the ti's comedy itself weeds
people out
oh it does and it was a super chat by
the way
nice
give him a super chat horror give him a
power
thanks ryan
very cool there they go
thanks ryan but that's great comedy does
weed itself out i think the hard part is
t.i is such a celebrity like he's one of
those people that now because of this
incident especially with lauren knight
like now people are watching and like
like hoping for something to happen it's
kind of like the slap right it's like
you know everyone's watching what chris
rock is gonna say everyone's watching
every move by will smith like it's like
now you're under that microscope
yeah so
if he doesn't get funny like
soon to your point doesn't get like a
hot tight five
it's not gonna go good
unless he like unless he does it more
because i'm sure he's like four moves
ahead i'm sure he has a whole plan i
think he just shot like a movie or a tv
show with a bunch of
i thought you were about to say he just
shot a special special
like
i think
i wouldn't be surprised actually
if he's already got a development deal i
mean yeah he's already cooking up a lot
of things i'm sure he is he's talking to
the people that own the building that we
perform at you know i'm saying like
that's different level type stuff like
you mean like yeah he probably has the
mayor's number in his uh rolodex you
know i'm saying yeah so yeah you're
probably right he's probably thinking
way
way many like steps ahead of us
but you still gotta be funny man you
gotta be it's it's just gotta be funny
it's gotta be funny
yeah uh like dennis thule said comedy
isn't like baseball we don't have minor
league
to prepare comics for the big leagues
everyone has a different path to success
for sure
i mean he's having he's just doing all
this under a microscope so everything he
does
is gonna get blown up
but if he's heckling other comedians it
should get blown up i mean that's yeah
that's that's like
that's just fundamental 101
that's being a good person not heckling
yeah yeah it's just being a good person
yes yeah because this is
those things are going to come out
but that also hurts
your personality from a stage presence
perspective
because if that's who you come out to be
as like
like a-holes in comedy don't make it you
know i'm saying like no one books an
a-hole like yeah
work you if they like you and want to
see you succeed and then want to see you
actually do your jokes in front of their
audience that's how you get booked yeah
but you know comedy owners aren't
booking people they hate or people that
are like
going to berate the crowd
you mean
yeah that's william
williams said treat him like any other
comic just starting out be honest and
upfront with him and tell him about hot
breath pro and patreon
we'll send you a promo code t.i yeah
yeah yeah
yeah tia use these promo codes to get
you get you a class that's what mookie
said look he said take the class
hillary oh mookie said that
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah it doesn't really
stand for anything i think it's just
uh
it has to right
i don't think it does
chris crystal connor said get that
testimonial from ti hot breath pro
changed my life
changing the game son changing the game
[Laughter]
this is what clifford harris said yes
i like seeing other people say there are
three things they would tell ti too
that's interesting yeah jlegg said
understand there's a craft all
performing respect the craft of comedy
and respect the audience
shane lake said t.i stands for terrible
improviser oh
my gosh
bars
[Laughter]
snap shots fired
said ti is the new brendan's shop
i mean that's
it's like it's like people would throw
shade at brendan schub
he shot a special super quick it's it's
it's tough because
it's like
don't hate the player hate the game if
the game is putting butts in seats
it's like brendan schaub
jumped way far but yeah brynden
had access to comedians like joe rogan
which ti has access to the best
comedians in the world
so brendan actually listened to them and
applied what he learned and took it
seriously he wasn't out taking comedians
he like
he went through he went through the open
mics and all that like he had maybe an
easier path because of who he is but he
still has been putting in the work so so
he will he's still committed to actually
taking it seriously which is not
something
we've really seen from ti yet but
hopefully maybe this will change it
yeah hopefully he watches this
and changes
everything yeah
chris said this is the comedy equivalent
of jordan retiring and going to play
baseball
[Laughter]
very true
very true those are facts those are
facts and i think like we were talking
about before the show like i think
there's sometimes
even if you're good at one thing doesn't
mean you're gonna get be good at another
thing
like um
you know me like not every entertainer
should be in crypto you know what i'm
saying like i get it
yeah yeah yeah like an opportunity but
like what do you know about finance or
what do you know about bitcoin right
it's like
yo like not everything is suited
to be marketed or like you can just get
into because
you're good at one thing
big facts
oh well we good uh bobby said tell ti
the room is only open for so many
minutes step on another comics minutes
they may step on you
as you try to climb the comedy ladder of
success
yeah
ryan said i wouldn't hate to get slapped
by t.i i could use the
dude if i got slapped by t.i just know i
won't be on the show next week
it's going to be sponsored by hot breath
we're going to be we're going to be in
the maldives
if i get slapped by a guy
so are you are you for it like what is
what is your take are you are you four
or five percent here
to do what are you for ti like pursuing
comedy oh yeah i want him to be
successful
i just believe
that
you do have to follow
the human rules of comedy of like not
heckling not being an a-hole like
those are just common everyday rules
that still applies to comedy like not
disrespecting the light not like
coming to shows with like
in essence like i get like if you come
to the show with like people to protect
you from a personal perspective but like
also maybe bring a comedian friend
like bring an advisor like i i'm just so
surprised that he comes to shows and
there's not a comedy person next to him
just being like
you know hey
that was a good set because it feels
like no one's telling him
that he's not doing it in the right way
or like he's not doing it in
like whatever he's doing
like it's as if though no one's like
advising him and it's like yo your ti
you can afford a consultant
i'm sure he's been getting consulting
maybe now more than ever as people like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa bro whoa
whoa whoa
[Laughter]
so yeah i'll be i'll be interested to
see what comes of it but i'm i'm hoping
you know these are just those early
growing pains that we all have to go
through as comedians that i'm hoping
we're gonna start to see
some more you know some more uh what we
call them in comedy uh jokes that's
right jokes
what's that thing that we used to do
back in the day oh yeah oh jokes set up
punchline
[Music]
but i i hope nothing but the best for
him i hope it really does work out for
him because it's just it'll be another
avenue for people to find comedians and
i'm sure he would use it as a way
to
um put other comedians on as well oh for
sure yeah and i think i'm hoping the
best that's that's the opportunity for
him to like make that leap and
definitely close the gap because you
know at the end of the day like ryan
said we're like we're all artists this
is all an art we all
want approval from people to be like yo
i vibe with you i like what you're doing
on stage we're all attention [__] here
let's let's let's
i know what this is
and i understand it um but yeah and i i
definitely want him to be successful but
you know i don't
i just don't
you know there's just some rules to this
game
and you got to be funny
like that's the other thing like
if it's constant that you're not funny
and you're breaking all the rules it's
like
what are we doing
[Laughter]
valid point yeah if we're not doing
jokes what are we doing
nice the ip really stinks for 10 inch
player
that's eclipse lawn care just googled it
he said
yeah
is that facts
i don't know man
that's funny though oh william's rooting
for him as well he just said he needs a
mr miyagi
to uh teach him how to wax on and wax
off
hopefully i i mean i'm sure
he needs to help he needs a hot breath
consultant package right that's what he
needs
that's what he needs yeah that's what he
needs we're here for your ti we're here
to help you we are here for you buddy
all right
mr harris if you need anything holler at
us clifford but i think the takeaway is
change your name to clifford and it'll
change a lot
it'll change a lot like because no one
wants to see ti on stage no everyone
will see i sing on stage but people need
to see clifford
because clifford can do like america's
got talent t.i can do america's got
talent yeah yeah yeah yeah that's jokes
i think it would be like a mindset shift
for him too because
he's not going as ti but liz moore
but i mean it's ti he'll probably just
stay as ti it's a brand and all that
i want to see clifford do comedy though
i think that really
that really takes away a lot of the bite
it takes like
imagine a comedy special called clifford
does comedy
oh my gosh
that's hilarious
[Laughter]
for sure
but it's a hot topic that i'm sure will
continue to evolve but um
we're rooting for him we're rooting for
clifford
he's